Congress is considering that very
question as it considers a
trillion-dollar stimulus to rescue the
economy from the effects of this
pandemic it could be the biggest bailout
in American history and that's after a
new poll shows nearly one in five
households have lost work already
because of this pandemic Nancy Cordes is
on Capitol Hill forests Nancy good
morning so this stimulus could mean
money in the pocket of everyday
Americans and soon what are the details
well Tony the big detail that a lot of
Americans are going to be interested in
is $1,000 that's the amount of money
$1,000 or more that lawmakers and the
White House say they want to send to
every American worker who's been hard
hit by this epidemic these payments
would go out in April that's this month
with another round to come down the road
if there is still a need now this
initiative alone could cost about two
hundred fifty billion dollars and while
they're still working out how much each
individual would get it could be
structured something like the tax
rebates you saw during the last
recession where you've got a different
amount depending on things like your
income level now there's a massive
economic stimulus package that's being
crafted this is a part of it it could
also include roughly 50 billion dollars
in assistance for Airlines and 250 to
300 billion in small business loans
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
told us yesterday that he is keeping the
Senate in town until they can vote on
this huge bill which could hope that
which could come they hope by the end of
the week another good piece of news for
a lot of taxpayers is that the Treasury
Department is now pushing back the
deadline for making tax payments of you
owe anything more for 2019 by 90 days
that's for individuals and businesses
though they are still advising that if
you are owed a refund that you go ahead
and file your taxes on time by April 15
all right Nancy thank you